dans les zones d'alerté maximale c'est
donc parti pour quinze jours avec des
mesures afin de tenter de freiner le
regain de l'épidémie pour les
entreprises la ministre du travail
elisabeth bornes rappelle la nécessité
de privilégier plus que jamais le
télétravail et pour revenir sur ces
annonces et ses conséquences place à
notre décryptage
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
fabrice division avocat bonsoir art côté
olivier maire et au patron du meeting un
bar restaurant dans le 19e
arrondissement de la capitale bonsoir
nous a rejoint également alexis poulain
éditorialistes bonsoir alors à distance
entre les tables carnet de contacts gel
hydroalcoolique sur toutes les tables
désormais un nouveau protocole sanitaire
est donc mise en place dans les
restaurants
olivier marais tôt quel est votre
sentiment est ce que vous êtes
finalement soulagé de ne pas fermer ce
soir ou alors inquiets face à de
nouvelles mesures contraignantes
un avis très partagés partagé parce que
encore une fois on est prévenus au
dernier moment
alors à l'heure actuelle on n'a pas
encore le texte officiel 1 sur ce qu'on
doit appliquer exactement heureusement
les syndicats etc
quand même fait leur boulot et nous ont
donné les grandes lignes
aujourd'hui c'est une profession qui a
encore stigmatisé
on sait par les cafés bars des restos a
alors que les cafés bars et la vie d'un
quartier
aujourd'hui ils doivent fermer c'est pas
uniquement de la vente d'alcool à un bar
uniquement qui a des tables aujourd'hui
on va pas qu'on comprend pas pourquoi il
peut pas accès à accepter des clients
les installer et faire un service à 6
comme dans un resto voilà après pour les
mesures qui nous sont propres
on a la chance aujourd'hui de pouvoir
ouvrir et quand je dis la chance il va
falloir faire les calculs on avait
jusqu'à maintenant le temps qu'ils
étaient pour nous les terrasses ce que
j'appelle les terrasses hidalgo les
extensions terrasse quand vous avez
comme nous avaient données qui nous
permettait d'avoir une activité
cohérente aujourd'hui les gens vont se
mettre à l'intérieur de nos de nos
affaires et on a une obligation de
rentabilité qui est clair et avec toutes
les restrictions qui sont mises
aujourd'hui pas falloir faire le calcul
parce que c'est encore rentable d'ouvrir
ou est ce qu'il vaut mieux fermer en
attendant que ça passe et mettre tout le
monde au chômage partiel et pour nous
les patrons faire le dos rond parce que
les indemnités sont inexistantes
on va le savoir très rapidement en tout
cas à propos de ces nouvelles
restrictions concernant les bars et les
restaurants
regardez ce que disait hier le ministre
de l'intérieur gérald darmanin bien sûr
que c'est difficile nous sommes les
français nous aimons boire manger vivre
sourire nous embrasser mais nous le
faisons évidemment parce que la
population aussi le souhaite alors
alexis poulain au fond le gouvernement
répond à l'attenté des français comme
viande comme l'expliquent gérald
darmanin
non absolument pas le gouvernement dans
cette affaire depuis le début gère la
pénurie en mars il gère la pénurie de
masques alors les masques ne sont pas
nécessaires et qu'est-ce qu'il se passe
confirme en général aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qu'il gère la pénurie de lits
la pénurie de formation de soignants à
la réanimation
donc on fait semblant on va re confiné
d'une certaine façon on force les
restaurateurs à fermer ou bien mettre
des mesures coercitives avec
l'interdiction de la vente d'alcool à
partir de 22h les bars qui ferment tout
cela n'a aucun sens parce que
aujourd'hui nous l'apprenons en région
parisienne et à paris
203 des clusters qui sont sortis sur les
203 kuster 40% c'est à l'école et à
l'université
hélas une seule mesure sur l'université
c'est le présentiel différé sur l'école
rien du tout ce gouvernement dans cette
crise sanitaire n'a jamais rien fait
pour prévoir pour planifier pendant
l'été on a vu et emmanuel macron sur un
jet ski on a vu jean michel blanquer air
à la plage il ya eu des conseils de
défense bien entendu mais tout a été
fait comme si la rentrée allait se
passer sans encombre comment ils ont pu
penser ça une seule seconde
le d
confinement qui a été gérée au cabinet
américain bain and company la filiale
française est un fiasco total géré par
un monsieur qui s'appelle jean castex ce
qui se trouve être notre premier
ministre
ça devrait nous poser des problèmes
comment ces gens qui ont si mal organisé
le déconfinement peuvent-ils aujourd'hui
gérer la vie avec le virus avec
uniquement des mesures coercitives qui
ne sont pas du tout ce que demandent les
français contrairement à ce que dit
monsieur darmanin les français ils
demandent simplement à ce que les
gouvernants gouvernent c'est à dire
qu'il défende les intérêts nationaux
qu'ils défendent les populations face à
une crise sanitaire qui les dépasse
aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'ils sont
dépassés
la preuve en est faire référence
demander de l'aide au secteur privé avec
le cabinet bnm compagnie la même chose
pour l'usiné bridgestone ont fait appel
au privé pour dire comment sauver les
emplois
non ces gens là sont élus ils sont là
pour gouverner aujourd'hui ils subissent
cette crise et nous font subir leur
incurie je crois que on a été
suffisamment patient à marseille je
comprends le choix de madame ribeiro là
de faire un conseil sanitaire à
l'échelle d'une ville parce que ce qui
se passe à l'échelle d'un pays
aujourd'hui c'est les shadoks alors
effectivement à marsa et samia ghali a
défendu la création d'un conseil
scientifique
fabrice di vizio vous voyez dire non ce
n'est pas une bonne idée pourquoi
n'importe quoi bien faire excuser moi
même ne trouvez pas que c'est
suffisamment le bordel comme ça ja
pardon pardon d'être franc mais ne
pensez pas que c'est suffisamment le
bordel comme ça vous avez un nombre
incalculable j'ai vu tout à l'heure il
disait renaud muselier 10 instance et 10
instance on en rajoute une ancienne et
leur tient au lac a effectivement moi
j'habite à rambouillet
là je voudrais bien aussi au conseil
scientifique à rambouillet j'ai un
hôpital et puis pas le droit j'ai une
clinique aussi à trappes
je voudrais bien conseil scientifique à
trappes il m'avait semblé comprendre que
l'état était unitaire dans ce pays que
nous n'étions pas dans des länder où
dans des états fédérés américains et que
effectivement le centralisme
ce n'était pas forcément un inconvénient
quand il était bien fait de répondre à
la réalité des territoires selon vous
ces personnalités ya pas de réalité des
territoires
il ya une réalité qui est de réalités
nationales on a un virus qui circule sur
le territoire national alors avec plus
ou moins d'incidents selon les régions
mais je veux dire alors demain matin
est-ce qu'il faut que marseille se dote
de son propre conseil de défense et de
son papa conseil de sécurité à quand une
police municipale armée est
effectivement un tribunal et une loi
marseillaise vous voulez quoi rétablir
les coutures bleues coutumier du mauvais
this fier parce qu'on en est là un
moment donné c'est à dire
qu'effectivement concrètement il m'avait
semblé que l'état unitaire et que
l'unité de l'état est un progrès dans
l'histoire du droit là tout à coup on
est en train d effectivement rester veut
restaurer des espèces de coutume locale
avec des conseils locaux
mais tout ça va engendrer une confusion
supplémentaire la vérité pardonnez-moi
mais relativement simple et je partage
au combien david alexis poulain sur ce
point c'est que nous avons un
gouvernement qui ne gouverne pas alors
est ce que parce qu'il gouverne pas il
faut que d'autres face à sa place ben le
problème c'est qu'on afin de faire un
coup d'état là peu ou prou il est là le
problème de fond est par ailleurs
j'avais vertu a répété depuis premier
jour dans cette crise que ce pays n'est
pas gouverné que des administrés mal
au demeurant nous n'avons pas de
gouvernement premiers éléments moi je
vis en temps partiel en italie et j'ai
un cabinet à rome regardez l'italie
l'italie à gérer le problème des le
déconfinement elle a masqué les gens il
ya un protocole universitaire via un
protocole social en france on a dit en
juin partez en vacances et en septembre
mais enfin mais kate vous allez faire en
vacances tout ça c'est de votre faute
et enfin dernier point sur les durées
animations pardonnez-moi vient on à 30%
des livres d'animation mais dieu soit
loué on pourrait en avoir 60
si le virus était arrivé dans deux ans
on aurait eu 60% des titres réanimation
qui aurait été occupée puisque toute
façon on les ferme et lits de
réanimation donc venir dire il ya 30 %
des lits de réanimation qui sont occupés
tout en fermant délit c'est forcément
biaisé un moment donné les statistiques
olivier mr et oh vous avez le sentiment
ce soir finalement 2
payer pour un certain amateurisme du
gouvernement amateurisme pour reprendre
les mots de bernard marty 1 c'est le
président de l'union des métiers de
l'industrie de l'hôtellerie en paca qui
disait ne pas voir bien clair dans ces
nouvelles mesures
depuis le 14 mars
on a réellement l'impression d'être le
marqueur de l'action politique du
gouvernement
dès qu'ils aient dès qu'on doit marquer
une action on agit sur nous ce que
disait votre éditorialistes tout à
l'heure
40% des clusters dans les universités 26
% dans les entreprises 10% dans le
cercle familial
là les chr n'apparaissent nulle part et
pourtant et pourtant les principales
mesures qui sont prises sont contre nous
et sans nous donner de visibilité il ya
dix jours on nous allons nous as très
lié à servir uniquement après 22h des
gens qu'ils dînaient etc etc
avec toutes les dérives que ça comporte
un jeu vous donner un exemple très
rapidement jeudi soir les amis qui a une
brasserie de fait tout le protocole tel
qui doit être et 12 policiers qui
débarquent tous policiers c'est pas deux
policiers qui font du zèle
ça veut dire qu on a des directives et
qui les indigne pourquoi parce que les
gens qui sont à table et qui ont dîné
l'état brut et des services en train de
finir leurs bouteilles et bien dans
l'alcool doit accompagner que les plats
sains et donc fallu laisser les
assiettes sur les tables ce qui fait que
moi j'étais pas là ce week-end j'ai
donné comme directive ce qui est ce qui
est hallucinant au camp en tant que chef
d'entreprise d'un biais de dans la
restauration
j'ai donné les directives à mes employés
de ne pas desservir les tables ce qui
fait que tous les gens ont terminé leur
retard devant des assiettes sales
découvert salle pourquoi parce qu'on
avait la peur de se prendre un
avertissement il faut savoir qu'un
avertissement c'est pas un avertissement
de la fonction publique qui après cinq
avertissements donne un blâme et 5
grammes
une promotion et une mutation à un
avertissement chez nous 1 le deuxième
c'est d'une fermeture administrative
donc aujourd'hui on est dans une espèce
de je sais pas si c'est de l'amateurisme
en tout cas on est dans pour nous dans
une vision de l'avenir
et là on nous a donné des directives
pour cage
en nous disant que dans quinze jours on
fait un nouveau point donc là il va
falloir que je rajoute du jld à l'aise
sur toutes les taxes enfin bon il ya
plein de petites mesures des petites
mesurettes qui change strictement rien
en fait au fonctionnement du bistrot
sinon nous apporter les nouvelles
contraintes et de nouveau moyen de nous
sanctionner et donc un jour peut-être
qu'on va fermer
peut-être que il se passera à autre
chose peut-être qu'il faudra qu'on
réduise encore de 25 30% les les tables
etc
il est donc pour nous c'est on a
vraiment l'impression d'être stigmatisés
et d'être encore une fois je retire
utilise l'expression parce que parce
qu'elle est vraie le marqueur de
l'action politique
alors on veut dire qu'on fait quelque
chose on nous tape dessus fabrice di
vizio donc les cafés les restaurants
marqueur de cette action aux politiques
en attendant on en parlait les écoles et
les universités
bon elles sont aussi concernés par ces
nouvelles mesures on le rappelle elle
représente 75% des clusters les
nouvelles mesures selon vous est-ce
qu'elles sont suffisantes elle ce
qu'elles sont efficaces ou alors il
aurait fallu peut-être prendre davantage
en compte le problème des clusters dans
les écoles et les universités
fabrice division est ce que vous savez
que le protocole sanitaire sur le lieu
de travail relatif au lieu de travail a
été allégé est ce que vous vous rendez
compte que aujourd'hui les open space
qui jusqu'ici le masque était
obligatoire en toutes circonstances et
bien ne l'est plus puisqu'on a accordé
des dérogations premiers éléments
deuxième élément sur les universités
vous avez entendu les ministres vous
dire que en fait les universités
n'étaient pas des clusters a entendu les
dire c'est pas des clusters vous avez
entendu le ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur à avoir l'outrecuidance de
dire que dans un bar on a un virus qui
circulent mais dans un amphi où il ya
deux mille personnes qui sont côte à
côte sur un amphi de 1200 places
eh ben ça le virus ne circule pas si
vous voulez qu'avec ça on est encore
confiance dans ce gouvernement il faut
sérieusement s'accrocher quand même non
c'est pas des amateurs
je répète depuis le premier jour
pardonnez-moi de réutiliser cette
expression c'est pas des masses amateurs
c'est des branquignols nous avons
affaire à des branquignols c'est tout à
des gens qui n'ont absolument rien
compris
ne savent rien il amer et macro avait
dit soyez des amateurs il a raison il
comblera pris au mot nous n'avons pas de
gouvernement dans ce pays nous sommes le
pignon probablement le pire
dieu soit loué nous ne sommes pas face à
ebola c'est tout ce qui nous console
alors ce que sinon on serait tous morts
alors en attendant ses métros bondés
beaucoup le souligne sur les réseaux
sociaux
c'est le cas du député la france
insoumise sébastien la chaux regarder
l'allemand ferme les bars les salles
interdit les rassemblements et les
événements mais les travailleurs
s'entassent dans des transports bondé et
dysfonctionnelle l' alerte maximale
summum de la politique incohérente de
macron face au co vie de 10,9 alors
alexis poulain à la mise du travail
elisabeth bornes elle appelle les
employeurs et salariés à s'organiser
pour recourir au télétravail autant que
possible dans les zones d'alert
renforcer et maximale est ce que c'est
une bonne réponse pour éviter de voir
les photos qu'on a vu et qui circule sur
les réseaux sociaux avec des rames de
métro bombay mais c'est une piètre
réponse qu'on parle d'amateurs fier de
branquignols ou de shadocks on voit bien
que cette gestion de crise n'a aucun
sens et qu'elle est incompréhensible
pour le commun des mortels marlène
schiappa était très fier ce matin
d'annoncer que le plan le nouveau
protocole sanitaire des bars avaient été
écrits dans la nuit mais enfin comment
on peut être fier d'annoncer une chose
pareille ça veut dire que dans la nuit
sur un coin de table on a dit qu'il
allait falloir mettre du gel
hydroalcoolique sur les tables et faire
empêcher finalement les restaurateurs de
travail et les métros ce matin
évidemment que dans les métros le virus
n'existe pas mais d'où ça sort comment
on peut dire des inepties pareilles des
mensonges pareil sur les biens sur les
amphithéâtres bondés dans le dans les
facultés
la rentrée n'a pas été préparé la
rentrée des entreprises n'a pas été
préparé non plus et voilà où nous en
sommes et plutôt que d'inciter au
télétravail ça va bien dans certains
secteurs on peut le faire mais ça veut
dire qu'il faut à la fois que le
management soit responsable que les gens
soient formés au télétravail qu'ils
aient les outils pour le faire
aujourd'hui tout ça marche dans certains
secteurs et encore et que que faites
vous de tous les secteurs où le
télétravail est impossible il faut bien
se rendre au travail et donc dans des
métros bondés
c'est un vrai problème est là aucune
gouvernement ni sur les métros ni sur la
façon de gérer les afflux de population
à un client dans les centres commerciaux
sur 5 ou 4 4 ou 5 mètres carrés bon très
bien alors là comment on va calculer je
ne sais pas mais encore une mesure
fantastique a annoncé par le préfet là
aussi formidables ces mesures de
coercition sont annoncés par un préfet
on n'a même plus besoin maintenant d'un
premier ministre ou d'un responsable
sanitaire
ce sont les préfets qui choisit par
emmanuel macron qui décide comment le
territoire est éclatée alors oui ça ne
gouverne plus sage erp une crise sans la
gérer parce que finalement on a affaire
à un gouvernement qu'ils n'étaient pas
prêts qui n'est pas fait pour ça faire
des fusions acquisitions ça marche
travaillé avec des cabinets privés de
conseil comme bnm compagnie ça marche
mais quand une crise sanitaire majeure
arrive il n'y a plus personne
et aujourd'hui je suis désolé c'est les
français qui font ce qu'ils peuvent pour
continuer d'aller travailler protéger
leurs enfants quand vous avez des
parents qui mettent leurs enfants dans
des nids à qu'ovide que sont les écoles
ou les facs
mais qu'est ce que vous croyez qu'ils
pensent les gens que c'est normal que
derrière on va faire confiance à ce
gouvernement qui continue de mentir qui
continuent de mettre des mesures
ridicules sur des bars des restaurants
qui ne sont pas responsables de la
contamination
donc je crois qu'à un moment c'est
normal qu'on n'est plus confiance c'est
normal que les régions les villes chacun
essaye de faire ce qu'il peut pour dire
moi je vais prendre en charge finalement
là où le gouvernement s'arrête parce que
aujourd'hui mais on voit bien qu'il n'ya
pas de stratégie
il n'y a pas de planification et que ce
virus si on va vivre longtemps avec eh
bien on va vivre longtemps avec des
mesures idiote comme celle qu'on est en
train de vivre en ce moment fabrice di
vizio parmi les travailleurs qui
prennent le métro les soignants qui sont
en première ligne
le directeur général de l'ap-hp martin
hirsch a dit souhaiter aujourd'hui que
l'espagne en renoncent à leurs vacances
de la toussaint qu'ils seront indemnisés
fabrice division vous qui défendez à des
professionnels de santé
comment cette annonce peut-elle être
perçue est reçu comme une provocation
c'est une provocation c'est la marque de
l'humiliation dire que nous avons à
faire un directeur général de l'ap-hp
nous avons affaire à un ministre de la
santé médecin un directeur général de la
santé qui a disparu d'ailleurs qui
effectivement sont capables du
il y ait des gens qui sont à bout de
forces moi je les vois tous les jours
les soignants dans mon cabinet ils sont
à bout de nerfs
à bout de forces ça va mal finir cette
histoire ne peut que mal finir
on ne peut pas faire travailler des gens
sentent heures par semaine on peut pas
faire travailler des gens douze mois sur
douze en réanimation en soins intensifs
au bloc chirurgical et le tout n'est
vous bien sans protection l'auto tenez
vous bien
aujourd'hui les nouvelles directives
c'est quand vous êtes testé positif si
vous n'êtes pas symptomatique venez
travailler
si vous n'êtes qu'à contacter et vous
n'êtes pas symptomatique
venez travailler ça va mal finir et le
jour où ça finira mal
il se trouvera toujours un juge à
distance de l'épidémie pour dire que
c'est pas de la faute du gouvernement
est de la faute du médecin parce que
c'est lui qui sera en première ligne et
que concrètement c'est ça que je vis
tous les jours dans le système
judiciaire c'est que les médecins paye
devant la justice l'incurie de l'état et
l'incapacité des pouvoirs publics à les
protéger
et ça va je le répète pardonnez moi une
dernière fois mal finir
ça ne peut que mal finir on lit cela va
finir par des suicides
ça va finir par des burn out ça va finir
par des fautes médicales
mais ça va mal finir olivier mr et oh le
mot de la fin alors les manifestations
restent autorisés à 1 malgré l' alerte
maximale est ce que l'on doit s'attendre
à une mobilisation des patrons de bars
des restaurants dans les prochains jours
je l'espère je l'espère vraiment pas ce
que l'on peut pas regarder se contenter
de regarder nous à faire mourir parce
que c'est ce qu'on est en train de faire
aujourd'hui on essaie de sauver les
meubles mais on les regarde mourir et il
y en a beaucoup qui sont à bout au bout
il ya des drames qui vont ceux qui vont
se nouer dans cette profession et et
c'est ce qui est terrible voilà donc
j'espère oui qui aura une forte
mobilisation
j'espère aussi que que les clients vont
pas céder à cette espèce de messages de
la peur qui est transporté qui
stigmatisent cette profession en dix ans
dans l'impression alors qu'on est d'en
haut
aucun cluster à caen alors qu'on a
l'impression que tout passe par chez
nous a donc je dis à nos clients
continuent à vivre continuer à respirer
venez le faire chez nous et puis puis à
tous les gens de la profession faut
rester uni en séparant les bars et les
restos on crée un clivage qui n'a pas
lieu d'être aujourd'hui resto unis et
groupés et battons-nous pour nos droits
et pour faire jaillir nos entreprises
merci olivier meyer eto'o je rappelle
que vous êtes patron du meeting bar
restaurant dans le 19e arrondissement de
paris merci avoue fabrice di vizio
elle rappelle que vous êtes avocat un
merci à vous également alexis poulain un
éditorialiste